[Music]
social media is a increasingly an
important channel
of importance to many brands
one reason is the massive reach provided
by social media
and the other reason is that users
self-select
into being connected to the brand on
very large platforms like facebook
and this is very helpful because this is
a set of interested users
that the brand can engage in very easily
and the
second advantage of that is by engaging
with those users
you obtain kind of free virality because
those users can
share your messages with their friends
and their networks
and that content uh gets engagement for
free
and the third advantage is that those
users that
your connected users share your content
with
are also likely to be more interested in
you as a brand
because of what sociologists refer to as
homophily or
birds of a feather flock together
because these users
are connected to each other socially
they are
more likely to like you as a brand
what we were trying to understand is
what causes
good engagement and what is the effect
of that engagement in terms of brand
power and
value for the brand and what kind of
content gets good engagement and in what
way
we are very lucky to be able to partner
with a data analytics company which
serves as a consulting company
to approximately a thousand very large
firms that does advertising and
messaging on facebook
we were able to track for a period of
about
six months to eight months every post
we analyzed about 100 000 messages
and then we built a natural language
processing algorithm by which we
classified various attributes of that
content when we looked at what kind of
content produce meaningful engagement in
terms of shares
likes and commentary we find that the
inclusion of brand personality content
in a message
produces a massive amount of lift or
improvement
in engagement when we look at the
inclusion of performance content for
example information about prices or
deals or coupons
we find that it produces very little
engagement as you get more engagement
news feed or algorithms will give you
higher ranking
and then you get exposure to more
consumers in that sense
reach begets more reach more eyeballs
will get you more eyeballs and one of
the things that we found in the data
is that brand seems to be doing either
one kind of messaging or the other
but often not both for example you will
see one company doing a lot of
performance advertising
but very little little brand personality
advertising
we do find that performance advertising
is pretty good for driving path to
conversion
but because of the advantages of brand
personality content which generates
engagement and contributes to long-run
brand capital
and at the same time begets more
engagement through the role of
algorithms we think that it's actually
very helpful to include some kind
of brand personality content in your
social media media strategy
so mixing things up is really good and a
quote unquote um portfolio approach of
mixing in content
is something that is quite helpful and
nike is a very nice example of a company
that manages to engage
with its audience athletes and others
in a very meaningful way while at the
same time making sure that you have
access to discounts
and other kind of performance
advertising that is required for
immediate
conversion
marketing has now become a very
data-driven field and as part of that
evolution
we can now collect actual data on what
consumers and human beings actually do
which is vastly superior
to stated intentions data and i think
that is the holy grail
of marketing because a lot of
expenditures on marketing tends to be
targeted at people who either don't
respond to it or would have bought
anyway
in which case you should think of it as
a as a cost not a benefit
just because i bought something after i
see the ad doesn't mean that the ad
cost me to buy it so trying to
understand
attribution and causality remains an
open challenge so i think that that's a
very exciting time
where computational social science will
be very important for the community
but at the same time there is a huge
need for better education
and better training of both scientists
as well as managers
to see how we can put statistics and
data science correctly
and in an efficient way to improve the
[Music]
field
[Music]
you